with the 2022 beijing olympics soon
coming to a close
team china is celebrating its highest
winter medal tally ever it was the
second time the chinese capital hosted
an olympic event
but gone was the festive atmosphere of
the 2008 summer games
it's very different now so the novelty
to a certain extent has worn off it's a
winter games which by its nature is a
smaller event it's winter so so people
you know aren't outdoors as much and
then of course we've had kovid so all of
those things point to a more muted
atmosphere
here helpers in protective suits and
morning corvette 19 tests were a part of
daily life
olympic dreams ended abruptly for those
who tested positive for the virus it
seems pretty unreal that of all the
people
what happened to myself
i have been doing everything in my power
to stay free of covet since the start of
the pandemic
for some strict quarantine measures were
too much to bear many complained about
heavy-handed controls
i am
we are not even sure i will ever be
allowed to return to the village
and obviously this is very hard for me
top competitors weren't the only ones in
the spotlight
chinese tennis player pong shui appeared
in the stands with international olympic
committee head thomas buck after giving
an interview denying she made sexual
assault allegations against a retired
politician
rights groups criticized the decision to
use a uyghur athlete to light the torch
at the opening ceremony
and the featuring of a soldier who
fought on china's border with india
incensed new delhi
more anger was sparked after 15 year old
russian figure skater camilla valeeva
was allowed to compete after testing
positive for a bad substance we'll do
everything to investigate this this case
properly and the dopping of children is
evil and unforgettable
this olympics the irc fielded difficult
questions about china's human rights
record previous games held in russia
sochi and brazil's rio de janeiro raised
similar questions from here the summer
and winter olympics will return to the
western world held consecutively in
paris milan and los angeles
venues less likely to attract protest
the organizers of the beijing olympics
hope the legacy of the event will be
felt in a burgeoning winter sports
industry
and confidence that the city can pull
off a successful games despite a global
pandemic
katrina u al jazeera beijing